the Joe Rogan experience a great micro
version of what we're talking about is
the Capitol Hill autonomous zone which
turned out to be the home Joe from
Ballard yeah and you know it's so
interesting it's like of course it would
be on Capitol Hill yeah that was like
our little Haight Ashbury of sorts but
you know I thought Capitol Hill had had
really jumped the [ __ ] shark a long
time ago when I was reading an article
about people wanting to be on Capitol
Hill so bad that they were willing to
live in shared apartment living space
scenarios where they're sharing
bathrooms and kitchens and all this and
paying like stupid money for a room and
I don't mean a room in a house I mean
purpose-built habitation scenarios to to
do that and I'm just like why the [ __ ]
do you want to live there that bad I
mean there's plenty of cool [ __ ] there
but they flamed cool [ __ ] all over
Seattle what was it about Capitol Hill
because I'm not a Seattle guy it was
just you know it was the it was the gay
or LGBT I guess now as you would refer
to an epicenter there was a lot of there
had some headshop stuff it was just sort
of a counterculture district you know
and I remember as a kid you know we'd go
up there and go to the weird little
store that would be the place where you
want to buy some like crystals and it
would be there but it was a groovy very
densely cultural place and you know
famous for a lot of things you know some
things unfortunate like me as a Potter
getting killed behind the comet tavern
or but also for many many great things
too but it was it would definitely be
the place where you would see something
like a Chas pop-up it's just that the I
the the the separation from idea to
reality was something like a Chas is and
it's always going to be this case it's
always going to be just mountains in
between the two you know the funniest
part I think for me is watching that
altercation video with Raz and his his
his new police
we're the police now and the guy in
being approached for graffitiing a
building going well you know what's up
with all the guns and all the guys got
all these guns and this lady who's
filming going don't don't worry about us
having guns who cares about guns cops
carry guns guns ain't no big deal well
they basically made all the worst
aspects of a country they put up a
border immediately they kept people from
going and they had no medical they had
no police yes their police was a bunch
of thugs if something went wrong they
beat people up attacked him right one
guy was filming things they didn't like
him everything so they jumped him yeah
beat his ass yes Raz and the guy then
embracing each other which to one side
I'm thinking see I [ __ ] told you
people violence isn't the worst thing in
the whole world like you know to be
perfectly honest violence can bring
people a lot closer together than you
think you know we've never trained
together but we know what it's like to
train so there's already this inherent
rapport between us and then the rapport
between you and anybody that gets on the
mat is almost sussed out immediately
because you just cannot we cannot be on
them in a situation like that and be
living on persona alone you need to
really be who you are and that might be
a really great fighter might be a really
mediocre one it doesn't really matter
everybody is generally toward their
purest self when put into that kind of
scenario it is the Chuck I can't say his
last name polo polo neck yeah by club
Colin Powell he's been on the podcast
he's awesome I listen to her he's a
Palin up
okay and he you know the line about you
never know who you are until you've been
in a fight like yeah
stroll on you really want to know who
you are get into a fight yeah but but
watching that and you know so the side
of me is going to see like perhaps you
know a little bit of fisticuffs could
could make things a little better you
know especially if we were to talk about
the blah mutual combat that exists in
Washington right which is religion I
think should be national to be perfectly
honest
like the problem I have with that is
that like they let people fight out on
the street which you should be aware
that if you get Kayode you're gonna mike
you might die I know I think an amount
off the conch that has to be included in
such a law you have to be like look
you're taking your life into your own
hands like legitimately if you do it out
in the dirt I know but we can't nerf the
world that much we just can't
it's just not possible and as much as we
would love to think about the ideal
scenario for everything you you you
can't there's always gonna be that one
ten whatever it's it's just not possible
and so and then you see razzing this guy
and say oh it's all good but it's just
like well but what if cops just got to
just smack people all the time I mean
that's part of the problem with with
police issues in general yeah I mean we
can go on about I've seen that you know
you get the arguments about stats from
the FBI and about the shootings and
unarmed shootings and all this kind of
stuff but they don't have stats for how
many times has a cop just beat someone's
ass right they don't have they don't you
know and it's a lot right and but with
the the the Chaz you this thing that the
saddest thing about all this even
besides I'll take an argument on this
even besides all the [ __ ] property
damage and they're just tearing
everything up and an obviously loss of
life right there is there's killed there
at least two right I think that more
seven people died seven people are dead
[Applause]